[Music]
with school districts around the country
grappling with how to reopen
safely many are missing a critical
figure a school
nurse pre-pandemic estimates showed only
40 percent of schools in the u.s
have a full-time nurse that shortage is
now especially problematic
when having a medical professional on
campus is essential
our senior medical correspondent dr tara
narula shows us why many districts
are now struggling i cover 20 schools
and you know it's difficult because
we're spread pretty thin across the
country school nurses like nollie hines
call the situation dire with many of
them juggling multiple schools at a time
the cdc's national recommendation calls
for one nurse for
every 750 students but most states
fall short california's average is one
to about
2200 students and our district it's
about
one to about 3 700 students so it's it's
a big problem when
we have 20 nurses serving 43
000 kids during a pandemic with still
many unknowns
the importance of a school nurse on
campus is more critical than
ever we have over 75
kids who have diabetes and we're doing
management of kids with
really severe medical problems like
severe asthma sickle cell anemia nurses
say part of their job now
entails training school staff like
teachers and clerks
to handle medical emergencies from
asthma attacks and anaphylaxis
to seizures it's unfair to put teachers
and school staffs in that position
michael mulgrew the president of the
united federation of teachers
says the shortage of nurses adds
pressure on an already strained system
what burden does this place upon
teachers who are then expected
to step into that role well that's been
the
society shame for quite some time now
that the teacher can handle everything
of course they will do everything in
their power but they're not medical
professionals
but for years teachers have been filling
the growing void
according to the national association of
school nurses 25 percent of schools in
the u.s
have no nurse at all and 35 percent only
have a part-time nurse
this at a time when the nurse's
responsibilities are expanding
they have to make the medical judgment
whether it's corona
or whether it is something else then
it's the isolation
of whoever the individual is then
coordinating with the department of
health
to make sure that that person has access
immediately to a covid test
that all now goes to our nurse lori comb
from the national association of school
nurses
says the issue all boils down to lack of
funding
77 percent of school nurse funding
is from education dollars and so their
mandate is education
not necessarily health care she says
they are pushing the federal government
for 208 billion dollars
as part of the safer return to schools
coalition to provide the resources
needed to make schools safe for opening
as a parent would you send your child to
school this fall
if that school did not have a nurse my
community has a high rate of
transmission
so probably not at this moment
the pandemic also presents new obstacles
like mental health issues
an area nurses routinely help students
with says florida nurse
lisa kern they are lifesavers from a
physical standpoint
and then from a counseling and mental
health standpoint
as well they make a difference in the
lives of children every day
reopening protocols vary greatly from
district to district
but for schools working virtually nurses
are still working on case management for
students who have chronic health
conditions
they're also creating health plans for
students in case of an infection
many nurses say they're also using this
time to adequately train school staff
in infection control procedures and
process so important tara we heard
some of the nurses discuss the need to
be in school for more reasons beyond the
physical
what other things do they actually
handle
well lori comb in the piece said it
really well to me she said kids come to
school caring much more in their
backpack and than just their books and
homework and so
the nurses are really able to identify
the whole child including any social
needs vulnerable children
and also to pick up on those emotional
issues children may be having when they
come in with
a headache or stomach pain and it's
really anxiety or depression
so they're really the sentinel on the
front line yeah and there aren't enough
of them as you said tara thank you very
much